I have found it I have found the single
most perfect depiction of liberalism
ever
someday this photo will hang in a museum
the title will be liberalism year 2022
colorized the photo
is going around the internet right now
it's of a California man charging his
electric car with a portable gas powered
electricity generator it's a depiction
of a real thing in a real time and place
California actually cannot sustain its
power grid right now because of the
state's stupid left-wing energy policies
the only way that it has any hope of
making it through is by begging
residents to stop using power but
this is also a depiction of a broader
concept the libs upending tradition
overturning Society rejecting reality
only to watch as their crazy schemes all
of which relied on tradition and reality
collapse under their own weight
their own instability and then to be
forced to return to the tried and true
old ways except that they have to return
to them in the least efficient ways
possible you especially see this with
you know religion and kind of
traditional morality that's what all of
liberalism rests on then they try to get
rid of that and then the edifice falls
apart and then they have to try to
reconstruct religion and morality it
doesn't really work you look at the
engine gas and diesel-powered car
engines have very sophisticated emission
control technology
portable electric generators generally
speaking do not they're filthy the whole
thing is in fact much worse for the
environment than any of the normal cars
that normal people drive
pretty soon there's an idea pretty soon
maybe the libs will figure out that the
whole thing will move more smoothly and
efficiently if they just take that
portable generator that they've got and
and put it inside the car
and maybe they could put it underneath
the hood of the car
and then they could they can actually
take it with them on their drives and
they don't need to stop for an hour to
recharge the car at the special Port
they can actually just kind of pull over
at a at like a station
at a station that has gas at it and then
they refill the generators with gasoline
and then that will will charge their car
for the rest of the ride that is my
advice really high tech advice to all of
our listeners in California I will not
be following that advice myself because
I fled that liberal Wasteland and now I
live in Tennessee which despite having
much hotter Summers is believe it or not
able to keep the power grid running just
fine what a difference good government
and sane politics can make big headline
here in the Washington Post a big cause
of Celebration among the libs
there's a new conservative prime
minister in the UK
and when I say conservative that the
Tories the UK conservatives are they're
really more like American Democrats and
then the left in the UK is much further
left even than we're seeing in the
mainstream in America right now
so the conservative party
has just elected this lady Liz truss and
here's the headline Liz truss's cabinet
is the UK's first without a white man in
any of the top offices
and my reaction to that all the libs are
saying this is great this is wonderful
this is such a big win for justice and
equality and diversity and and my
reaction was
that's kind of weird isn't it
it's because England
is a country
of the English
and the English are definitely very
white they are they are some of the
whitest people on earth
and so isn't it kind of we and Men you
know you generally speaking usually are
involved in politics uh historically
speaking men are most of the people
involved in politics so it's just kind
of weird that in England a country of
extremely white people
you wouldn't have
even a single white guy in any of the
big government positions and that kind
of
I'm not saying it's necessarily the
worst thing in the world I'm just saying
isn't that it's weird it's not the sort
of thing that I certainly not something
I would celebrate
the the only reason you would celebrate
this is if you think white men are bad
which is
what the culture says right now the
culture said when it comes right down to
it beyond all the really super clever
arguments that we all try to make and
beyond all the damage of the real
racists and all that stuff
there is a sense in the culture that
that white people broadly white men in
particular but white people broadly are
just bad
and white people are the only group that
you are it is socially acceptable to
insult or discriminate against that you
can legally discriminate against Asians
sometimes bear the brunt of it too in in
University admissions but white people
you can discriminate against them
through affirmative action and just in
the culture it's the only racial group
that you're allowed to Mock and actually
encouraged to mock
I think that seems kind of wrong doesn't
it and there's there's nothing that the
white people can do about it because it
it has nothing to do with the actions
that the white people take the culture
has just said white people are bad a
great example of this is when white
people move neighborhoods when white
people move into a black neighborhood
that is bad because that's
gentrification
but when white people move out of a
black neighborhood that is also bad
because that's white flight
so there is nothing the white people can
do that would not be bad and that's
because the goodness or Badness of it
has nothing to do with the actions it
has nothing to do with which
neighborhoods you move to or from it
just has to do with the white people
doing it because the white people are
doing it according to the culture it has
to be bad because the white people are
bad you see this when if white people
adopt some aspect of another culture
let's say they they I don't know they
eat tacos or something they wear certain
aspects of clothing
that is bad because that's cultural
appropriation they're not allowed to do
that
but but if white people don't adopt
aspects of other people's cultures that
is also bad that's called cultural
Erasure that's called
eurocentric you know cultural chauvinism
or something and they that's bad too why
is it bad because it has nothing to do
with the tacos and it has nothing to do
with the clothing it has everything to
do with white people doing it whatever
the white people do is defined as bad
this is what you're seeing reflected
right now in the Democrats and the
Republicans on the issues of so-called
election denial or political violence
when the Democrats deny many elections
going back at least 22 years now to the
2000 presidential election and
increasing in recent years 2016. Hillary
hasn't really conceded that race she
still says that it was a stolen election
Stacy Abrams hasn't hasn't really
conceded at all the 2018 George gubern
Trailways she still says it was a stolen
election
well it doesn't matter
that's fine that's good when when the
left burns the country down for eight
months with BLM and antifa that's fine
that political violence is fine it's not
even violence it's mostly peaceful
but when any Republican
suggests that hey maybe it's a little
weird that they changed all the election
rules
radically unlike anything we've ever
seen right before the 2020 presidential
election maybe that's a little weird
maybe that raises questions when some
grandmas from the from the Midwest show
up to the capital rotunda and in many
cases are let in by police on January
6th that's considered the worst violent
Insurrection in American history that
was almost a coup d'etat
why it has nothing to do with
questioning elections it has nothing to
do with even political violence it has
everything to do with who does it
when the Democrats do anything it's good
when the Republicans do anything it's
bad Democrats could I was trying to
think of an example you know that would
be really egregious that were
hypothetical but I'll use a real one
Democrats could
could wear satanic symbols in in leather
harnesses in their professional
headshots that would be considered good
a republican could help a little old
lady cross the street that would be
considered an act of evil because of who
they are
so what's the takeaway from that
you've got to tune out the noise you
know there are a number of
Republicans who are very eager to hand
it to the Liberals to Grant certain
premises well you know actually the
Democrats have a point when they say
that the horn hat guy got a little out
of control actually you know Trump
shouldn't have used this certain kind of
rhetor no they don't
they don't have a point
you don't have to hand it to them
actually the whole argument is
disingenuous
no no one on the Democrat side cares
about racism none of them care about
political violence none of them care
about questioning elections
they just want to beat you they just
don't want you to do anything that will
give you an advantage you do not have to
take any of that stuff seriously I'm so
glad you like that clip look we hit a
million subscribers that's great I want
to go 2 million I want to go 5 million I
want to go three quadrillion ring that
Bell get the notifications we'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]